because it's dangerous to meet heroes
yes don't you think well yes yeah no
really I mean it I do I really agree
with you that when you idolize somebody
if you meet them there's always the
chance that they will disappoint you
that they will not measure up they're
like when you met Milton Berle how was
that he was not really of my time so I I
don't know I I didn't grow up with
Milton Berle I just did could you do so
much of his stuff that's what come on
it's local mill tea you gotta do it I
would say I was very worried to me like
well just what you said when I grew up
and I was watching the people that were
on TV when I was 10 11 12 or even
younger when I met Dick Van Dyke Mary
Tyler Moore when I met those people and
they were on my show that freaked me out
because that people had come out of my
childhood and I was talking to them I
was very nervous
more so than Tom Cruise that's my point
not nothing it's Tom Cruise but it but
it's you know you're Tom Cruise sing I
could be in a Mission Impossible Conan
O'Brien could be that's what you're
thinking thought-bubble
but wait now in this scenario now I'm
brain damaged I could I'm thinking I
could Mission Impossible Conan O'Brien I
could I could be a Mission Impossible I
could
like amico Brian Papa I think no sense a
satyr seven-year-old but I'm just saying
that when you meet you know like you
know I met Sinatra I met the great
heroes of my childhood it's it's the
best yeah
well I especially when you as you know I
didn't feel like I grew up I was a I
wasn't a child but when I watched at CTV
I idolized you John Candy mr. Flaherty
all the people that made that TV show
that was a such a huge part of my
formative years and my wanting to be in
comedy watching what you and your
friends were doing that meeting you was
freaky the first time I did and then I
grew to despise you over time you get
over it pretty quick yeah oh you get out
of the Martin Short experience real fast
certainly you got rid of respect right
away
[Laughter]